Um, so I went to, uh, realia. Now here's the deal, my opener.
Who's going to remain nameless now because he doesn't deserve the credit at this
point. Okay. Because let me show you how I am.
If you could imagine how I am. So he was,
I said, Hey, we've got a, we've got two gigs in a really Canada.
He says, where's that? I say two hours from Toronto. And he goes, cool.
I love Toronto. And I think, well.
It's not Toronto.
So we, so he says, Hey, by the way,
I have a gig two days before the Toronto gig.
Um,
and it's in Chicago now I bring an opener because a lot of the
time, one of the main reasons I bring an opener is because I like to travel with
somebody. I don't like to be up. I'm a lonely boy, dude,
if I take flights across the country,
if I take international intern Intercontinental or just continental flights,
I'm a lonely boy. If I'm alone, you know, do you understand?
I buy cashews at the, uh, Hudson news and I'm eating them. Like I want them,
but I don't want them. I get salted almonds. Right. But I'm a lonely boy.
I hate them. Like,
I'm Oliver twist asking my police have more or whatever the that was.
I'm a lonely boy. I'm just eating because I'm a lonely boy.
But if I have Mike, whoops, if I have my opener
with me,
I don't need to get those things because I'm not feeling insecure and I'm not a
lonely boy. Okay. So he says, look,
I know you like to bring me because you like to pay me and you
like to, and you like to pay me for free for you not being a lonely boy.
And I say, okay. Yeah, what's common. And he says, well,
it just so turns out that I have a gig two days before in Chicago,
do you think that I could fly to Chicago?
And then the next day I could fly to Toronto since it's so close and meet you in
Toronto. And I say, you know what? Sure. Yeah,
of course I'll take the lonely boy flight.
So I take the lonely boy flight. Okay.
And he says the day before,
but the day before the lonely boy flight, right. He says, Hey, don't be mad.
And I go like this.
Too late. Okay.
Because if you're saying, Hey, don't be mad. I like being mad too much.
And I'm already mad. Um, so,
so he says,
and if you know anything about my opener already, you know,
he's a Dingus piece of. All right. So, and you know,
he's not, it, it, he's pretty dumb. Like he's in his life.
He's gone like this before, you know?
And so he says to me, I figured it out already,
dude, that's the best. Yay dude.
It's so awesome that he goes like this don't be mad. I figured it out.
Hey, don't be mad. I figured it out already.
Now there's a certain level of madness I get when that happens.
I want you to know about the levels of Matt. First of all, there's annoyed.
That's not that bad. It's like in a fun territory. You're like, God it.
They forgot to catch up. Whatever the.
Then there's a level of mad where you go like this. Oh, bro. I'm mad.
You tell me what the going on. I'm furious. And I'm yelling.
And then there's another level of mad on top of that,
where you go quiet, where you just sit back and you relax.
It's like when the it's like in the, in the, when I was watching the show,
the movie there's one movie where it was like a world ending movie,
whatever the by Roland Emmerich,
something called like deep horizon or impact of the tomorrow,
whatever the it was, where the big wave was coming.
And the dad and his daughter is like,
here at comes and they just hug each other. They're coming.
That's how calm I am. I'm watching this big wave come crash.
And I know everybody's dying. Okay. I'm in a movie.
I'm in a role in Emmerich movie right now when Mike says, Hey, don't be mad.
I figured it out.
I grabbed my daughter and I wait for that big wave because what the am I going
to do, dude?
So, so he says,
no. So I say yes.
So I, I, this is what happened. He said, don't be mad. I figured it out.
And I say, you forgot your passport. And he says, okay. Yeah.
I'm waiting for that. Wave.
The waves are getting a little bit bigger. Right? It was far away. I said,
you forgot your passport. And the wave that wave got a little bit bigger.
It went from there.
To there.
Here it comes. It's getting louder. And he says, so you know how,
I always bring my passport card with me.
And if you're an avid listener of congratulations podcast, you know,
that might.
Brought that once.
Try and get over the border. I, something happened.
I don't remember what the happened.
You remember the episode something happened where he had the passport.
And we were like, Oh, it doesn't work for the flight,
but we're driving over anyway. So it's okay. I was like, it better work.
And it did work. And he was like, yeah. And I was like, all right, you won.
Luckily dude, you had 19 and you hit and you got a two,
but you're lucky you should have kept the 19.
I don't like when works out for dummies, you understand,
you need to understand that you're a dumb and have the happen. And that's it,
dude, you deal with it. And that's how you learn. And if you're 35,
like he is sub Bay.
So.
He says, I have that. Cause I always have it because my mom made me get it.
Ha ah.
Ah, Oh.
Dude, his Dick is probably four and a half inches. And when it gets hard,
it's probably four inches. Do you understand his Dick?
doesn't even get bigger. It congeals. It like gets smaller but harder.
So anyway, so he says some.
Luckily my mom made me get my PA Hey dude.
Okay. So he goes like this. Um, so here's what I'm going to do.
And that wave got little bit bigger.
The wave, the wave, wait a second. I'm squint my eyes.
Did it double in size. Did it double in size?
So I grabbed my daughter a little harder and I pull her in
because maybe this is the big one. And he says,
I'm going to take a flight from Chicago
to Buffalo, New York, wait a second.
Did that wave get a little bit bigger?
My daughter puts her chin into daddy's shoulder. Okay.
So I say, and he says,
I'm going to have, I'm going to fly into Buffalo really early.
And then I'm going to have.
Some one.
Hey dude, let me tell you something. Let's let's, let's, let's cut back.
It's like one of those movies that begins and when it's like,
and the guy's like summed like that movie with Chris burns,
what's that guy's name is Chris ed burns. And he,
and it starts in he and he's dead. And he says, so I'm dead. Right?
And then it goes and it flashes back and you're like, all right,
I've got to find out how this guy died or American beauty when he's like,
this is the last day of my life. You know, I gotta,
we gotta find out what the happens. He's dead by the end of this.
That's what happens. He says, so, so let's cut back all the way back. Hey,
when you're saying don't be mad, I figured it out.
In no part of the rest.
Just have that conversation. Do you say the word someone.
You understand? Because if you figured it out, you know,
all right.
So that wave what I'm noticing.
It's getting real wide at the top, which means it's curling over.
It's not going to subside.
So I say, yeah, he says, someone's going to pick,
someone's gonna pick me up in Buffalo and bring me to the
Toronto airport while I use my passport card to get over the
border.
And I'll meet you when you land and can tell he's nervous.
But what I can tell even more is that wave
is gonna kill us. My daughter's crying at this point.
Okay. So I go like this. Okay.
And I hang up, cause your boy means business.
I don't hang up lately. I hang up heavily.
So say, okay,
the day comes where he hits me up. By the way, how far is it from Buffalo?
Two hours and five minutes. Wow. It's a hundred miles.
This moron. You know? So the day comes, hi, yada,
yada, I'm taking this and that a train. He took a train. He took every window.
He took a train, a plane, a car. This guy,
I expected him a half, expected him to show up with a or, and shorts on.
And um, I get to the thing, my, my flight's delayed.
I get in at 1:00 AM and he's sitting there and he's like, bro, I'm so tired.
And I look at him and I go good.
And I realized that wave and my daughter,
it didn't exist because it was all a movie. It was directed by Roland Emmerich.
It wasn't real life. He made it happen. But he learned.
And the thing about that is he didn't learn. He'll do it again.
But in that brief moment of time, he learned, and I,
uh, I didn't even really get that because there was no reason to,
I was either going to have an opener. I said, Hey man, you tell Andrew,
my agent, my high powered agent. I was like, you tell Andrew to,
make sure to get another opener on deck because bro, I'm not doing it alone.
And he was like, no, don't worry about it. And I was like, Oh, I said,
you know how Madam would be if there's an opener. Right. And he said, yup.
Anyway, wow, dude,